so one time i was in i went to college
in san antonio
and uh college a call called trinity
oh yeah so not a lot of jews at trinity
so i um we're out one night
and uh i um there's this woman
she was like 31 which that time that's
old man
sure meet her out at this bar and she
was
just basically i got a free night
basically she was with her friends
she basically was like i got a free
night and i'm ready to [ __ ] yeah they
don't mess around
yeah and i i was on board so i go back
and i'm 22 i was 21 or 22. go back to my
place now
my game plan is i just gotten a guitar
she said it's my birthday
can you play me a song guitar and i was
like
i didn't really i just got in like two
weeks before so i was like yeah
you know yeah come on back i'm gonna
figure something out for you she goes
can you play me happy birthday i'm like
absolutely i play happy birthday
so my game is this is the plan she's
driving back in her car i'm driving back
in mine
i'm going to get the guitar out and you
know noodle around a little bit
yeah whatever yeah but just a little bit
yeah but but maybe acapella a little
happy birthday and see if i can't slide
right into the panties
i come home my buddy tim tim was jacked
jack jack jack tim is wearing tidy
whities
hell yeah cowboy hat did he get on a
drum set or some [ __ ]
nope he's this is how he used to watch
tv tidy wadi's cowboy hat
get a half gallon of milk and a plain
baked potato and he would drink the milk
and eat the baked potatoes jesus christ
this dude was a baseball player no he
was
just a jack just jacked and [ __ ]
bananas
right and and he would drink the milk
out of the side of his mouth so he could
eat so it was always dripping oh wow
so he come home and he's sitting there
and he wouldn't sit on the couch he
would sit crisscross applesauce in front
of the couch and watch
tv so we come home and i get this
groaning last woman
with me and so
i'm like hey and she comes in and she
sees tim i'm like hey tim and he's like
hey man
and so he's just sitting he's sitting
there and he's drinking his milk and
he's eating his baked potato and um
and uh she sits on the couch a little
ways down from him and
i'm like can i get you a drink she said
cool and um
i go hey i just gotta use the restroom
real quick and i hand her a drink and i
go to the bathroom and i go to the
bathroom and
i'm talking myself up 31's oh at that
age yeah
that's a grown person oh yeah and
actually when you're in college
i'm psyching myself up i'm honestly you
ever when you were younger were you ever
worried about
performing sexually with somebody who
you thought was way more experienced
than you oh yeah
so that was my big thing i was just like
ah she's gonna
she's gonna she's gonna say something
like what are you doing yeah you know
what i mean i know you're amateur
yeah dude and so my plan was i was
talking myself
my plan was like i was going to say it's
your birthday so you tell me what to do
that was going to be my gift to you it's
whatever you want that's all
that's like i'm going to learn without
being embarrassed
right good plan i said it a couple times
in the mirror yeah
you know i was playing it up i was like
what do you want me to do yeah boy then
i tried my birthday
yeah i tried a little matter of fact
birthday girl it's your night yeah it's
just
you know it was basically the song from
twins tonight is your night bro
you know right so i had it all psyched
up and i walk out and and i maybe was in
the bathroom a little longer and i
thought
the tv is still on the milk and the
potato are there
but tim and the girl are gone oh tim's
[ __ ]
so i look in the kitchen gun tim's jack
dude tim
it's jack jack same six one a
solid 240. oh wow no like
like a solid a guy who you were like
even if he was wearing his tidy weddings
and a cowboy hat and you walked in you'd
be like yeah that's going to make sense
yeah
i'm on board with that he's basically
mike all stuck yeah yeah i'm like you're
doing good you're doing good yeah i got
no argument
and so i looked down into his room
and he just had the cowboy hat on his
doorknob and i was like
so i just kind of i did a couple of
light light just
just light you know what i mean are you
guys in there yeah i did a couple of
light locks
but i just the first night lock was
hello and the second like now what goes
i just
i didn't know if you still wanted me to
play happy birthday
somebody's birthday in here she's all
get out yeah dude
it was nice you mad at your buddy you
understand no good for you yeah
if in a seven minute period you could
turn the game around that quick
i i don't even know if that's worth it
if i don't know if that's more of his
game or her just being
[ __ ] hungry i think she looked at my
body and his
and was like i'm gonna go with this guy
she knew she was not going for a
boyfriend she was just out to get
[ __ ] she was 31 who wanted to date a
younger guy or have
sex with a younger guy and he's there in
his underoos already with a cowboy hat
on
knowing what your p she knows what he's
packing he's wearing he's got
body and his underoos on he might as
well just ask
you know he's probably a little simple
with milk in the potato a hundred okay
peanut butter falcon let's do this
yeah that's exactly what it was that's
what happened
and and by the way i had to listen to
them [ __ ] oh man
it was like and he came in did he say
anything when
when he came out so he came out right
and they finished and i went into my
room i didn't want i was in the living
room right
because my room was near there the room
so i mean i don't want to hear
too much you want to stand outside the
door and jack off no
no no it's college so that's what kids i
think that's what kids do
so she walks right past me
and he comes and sits down
picks up the milk picks up the baked
potato carries back carries right back
in
what a savage yeah and he just sat there
for a second and he was he just looked
at me he goes
sorry about that i was like man whatever
wow you're a good guy yeah man what do
you get listen what do you he didn't say
like man that was a real wild cat
later because he i go how was it he was
like man she was grown up
when i got off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what this front of a bunch of other
comics i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song